ersparen die erste Frage an Sie was
haben Sie gedacht als in dieser Woche
diese Beschlussvorlage gelesen haben das
ist die Lösung oder kommt mir bekannt
vor oder reicht nicht nur zwei drei
Dinge auf einmal gedacht zum ersten
kommt mir bekannt vor weil vieles von
dem was in dieser Woche diskutiert wird
wir schon seit Jahren diskutieren und
besprechen vor allem die europäische
Lösung und ich beginne den Glauben daran
zu verlieren dass diese europäische
Lösung gelingt und der zweite Teil ist
was ich gedacht habe da steht vieles was
wir seit Jahren fordern und was auf
einmal selbstverständlich von roten und
grünen vertreten wird wo man früher noch
in mancher Ecke für geschoben worden ist
also ist ja gut dass sie irgendwie
verstanden haben dass wir dieses Thema
besprechen und lösen müssen aber es hat
viele Jahre gedauert haben gerufen
ein Seehof habe ich diese Woche noch
nicht angerufen nein ähm weil sie gerade
sagen die europäische Lösung ich
Kollegen haben heute mal ein paar Zahlen
rausgesucht schon sehr interessant im
Januar 2023 haben aufgenommen
Deutschland
31.300 Menschen Frankreich ungefähr die
Hälfte 15.500 Italien knapp 9000
Portugal knapp 200 und Ungarn 5
ist das die europäische Lösung das ist
sie eben nicht das ist ja das Problem
wir haben
es gibt der hat ja mehrere Facetten ja
das erste Thema der europäischen Lösung
muss aus unserer Sicht sein dass wir an
der EU-Außengrenze die Verfahren
durchführen und auch die Kontrolle haben
darüber wer warum Europa Europäische
Union betrifft das ist übrigens
Beschlusslage der EU in mehreren Räten
seit Jahren seit Jahren dass wir das so
machen wollen wir machen es nur nicht so
wir hatten schon mal probiert auf
griechischen Inseln das probeweise
durchzuführen sogar von der eu-betrieben
aber es ist nie wirklich dazu gekommen
weil der zweite Punkt ist ja dass nach
eu-rechte eigentlich in dem Land wo man
zuerst ist der Antrag zu stellen das
Verfahren durchzuführen ist offenkundig
findet das aber nicht statt sondern es
gibt
geradezu ein ein Sog hinein nach
deutschland
hat mit Abstand die meisten Flüchtlinge
und Menschen die als wlantrag Stellen
aufgenommen in den letzten Jahren
vielleicht noch Österreich Niederlande
Schweden mit dazu und es hat natürlich
auch einen Grund warum wir attraktiv
sind als Zielland weil das hat eben auch
zu tun mit der Rechtsstaatlichkeit hier
mit den sozialen Leistungen die es gibt
und solange es auch da europäisch kein
gemeinsames kein gemeinsames Level kein
gemeinsames Niveau auch ein sozialer
Unterstützung an Rechtsstaatlichkeit
gibt solange wird es immer diese diese
ja auch unfaire Verteilung geben das ist
übrigens alleine Baden-Württemberg hat
so viel Menschen aus der Ukraine
aufgenommen wie ganz Frankreich so dass
wir wir können viel leisten wir sind ein
starkes Land aber wir können nicht die
Probleme Europas und der Welt alle in
Deutschland lösen Sie das war also wir
haben uns ja häufiger hier schon über
das Thema Migration unterhalten man
hatte das Gefühl da gibt es deswegen
sagte ich auch eingangs mal ein bisschen
grundsätzlicher werden
da gibt es ein Gefühl der kollektiven
Überforderung
in diesem Land und ich ich merke dass
hier an so Dingen wie das zum Beispiel
grüne Landräte plötzlich sagen sorry ich
habe den Glauben an das was die in
Berlin besprechen und beschließen
vollkommen verloren weil wir kommen so
nicht mehr weiter und sagen dir dann da
gibt es diese naive Vorstellung
offensichtlich auf diesen Planeten
Berlin das das Migration und auch
integration bedeutet stell einfach ein
paar Betten in irgendwelchen leeren
verlassenen Landgasthöfen zur Verfügung
aber natürlich ist Integration so
unendlich viel mehr also Kitas Schulen
die entsprechenden Lehrer Lehrerinnen
dazu dass das ganze System und alles ist
vollkommen überfordert im Moment das ist
der Eindruck ihre auch das Problem ist
glaube ich dass wir jetzt in einer
Argumentation drinstecken wo wir
Migration als etwas Gefährliches
betrachten etwas was uns bedroht etwas
was wir abwehren wollen während wir ja
auf der anderen Seite so wie
Einwanderung brauchen wegen unseres
Fachkräftemangels wegen fehlende
Nachwuchs im Handwerk wenn sie mit
Wirtschaft Vertreter entsprechende sagen
die alle wir brauchen mehr Menschen wie
kriegen wir das zusammen also
Einwanderung ja ganz dringend aber jetzt
Migration bitte schon an den
Außengrenzen abwehren die tonhallen sind
überfüllt das liegt ja daran dass wir in
der in den Kommunen vor Ort das nicht
vorbereitet haben dass wir jetzt wieder
angeblich überrollt werden das sind
immer diese Vokabeln die dann fallen im
Zusammenhang in Menschen das passt ja
nicht so richtig ich bin ja bei Herrn
Spahn wenn er sagt wir müssen an den
Außengrenzen kontrollieren sie sagen
kontrollieren um abzuwehren ich sage JA
aber das ist der steht immer so ein
bisschen dahinter dass wir eigentlich
Migration irgendwie vermeiden wollen
wollen
immer passiert wir gehen jetzt wieder in
diese Mantik ist etwas Bedrohliches ja
also es geht darum dass wir Migration
anfangen zu gestalten ja in diesem Jahr
1000 kann man Migration nicht einfach
abwehren sondern es geht darum wir
müssen sie gestalten um Sie in unserem
Interesse auch in diesem Land
praktikabel zu machen ja und dafür
müssen wir sortieren nämlich erstens es
gibt Menschen die sind individuell
verfolgt wir haben ein Recht auf Asyl
das ist nicht verhandelbar das sind
einzelne Fälle nur diese Menschen
sollten auch ein Asylantrag stellen
warum ist denn unser System überfordert
weil wir alle ja Moment weil wir alle
Menschen die Europa betreten oder dann
in Deutschland landen ein Asylantrag
stellen lassen das ist völlig
überflüssig in ganz vielen Ländern weil
diese Menschen nicht individuell
verfolgt sind dann gibt es Menschen und
das ist eine große Gruppe weil das sind
die Afghanen und das sind die Syrien und
Syrer die kommen aus kriegsregionen
dafür haben wir eigentlich ein
humanitäres Kontingent diese Menschen
hätte man schon 2015 mit einem
humanitären Kontingent aufnehmen können
da haben wir 30 000 genommen am Ende
sind mehrere Millionen gekommen
Entschuldigung mehrere hunderttausende
gekommen über die Balkanroute diese
Menschen hätten wir gezielt mit einem
humanitären Kontingent holen können und
dann haben wir Migration Menschen die
keine Perspektive haben die in Not sind
Sie zu uns kommen wollen auch die landen
an den Außengrenzen und da sagen sie
zurecht dass er ein Vorschlag von Herr
Knaus eigentlich seit Jahren dass wir
sagen diese Menschen müssen schnell in
ihre Heimatländer zurückgeführt werden
und dann müssen Sie sich bewerben können
um Einwanderung Europa aber das ist
genau das Problem wir können nicht nur
Pushback zurück Rechtsbrüche an den EU
ausgrenzen machen und sagen ihr könnt
nicht kommen wir schicken euch zurück
ohne den legalen Weg gleichzeitig zu
bieten an Einwanderung und zwar echte
Einwanderung und nicht nur Kraft
Fachkräfte Zuwanderung sondern
Einwanderung legal in die Europäische
Union
also der erste Teil den ich wichtig
finde ist und unbedingt geht's aus
meiner Sicht ist erstmal Kontrolle über
das was da passiert die Bürgerinnen und
Bürger die große Mehrheit jedenfalls hat
zurecht die Erwartung an den Start oder
an die Europäische Union Staaten
verbunden Kontrolle über Migration zu
haben zu wissen wer warum
unser Land unser Europäische Union
betritt wie das bei jedem Flughafen im
übrigen wenn sie irgendwo einreisen die
auch der Fall ist dann machen wir großen
Aufwand für diese Kontrolle zur
Kontrolle gehört zu entscheiden wer
warum es geht nicht darum zu sagen
keiner sondern es geht darum zu sagen es
gibt gute Gründe wenn man etwa eben
flieht Verfolgung dann auch tatsächlich
aufzunehmen es geht aber genauso gute
Gründe nicht aufzunehmen zurückzuweisen
an der Grenze und in das Heimatland oder
auch einen Durchreise Land
zurückzuweisen es gibt übrigens auch
rein rechtlich dass Asylrecht wenn Sie
das Grundgesetz nehmen sagt wir aus dem
sicheren drittsta kommt hat kein
Asylrecht in Deutschland da wir von
sicheren Drittstaaten umgeben sind hat
eigentlich niemand einer Asylrecht in
Deutschland nach dem Grundgesetz denn
für Flüchtlingskonvention hat eigentlich
den gleichen Geist trotzdem führen wir
eben rechtlich Einzel die Verfahren
der andere Ebene ist die Fachkräfte und
Arbeitskräfte Zuwanderung über
Fachkräfte bei mir daheim in Münsterland
machen die Kneipen mittlerweile dazu
weil sie überhaupt keinen Personal mehr
finden das auch nur da arbeiten könnte
Arbeits- und Fachkräfte Zuwanderung auch
da geht es natürlich um Kontrolle aber
da geht es darum die Frage wie attraktiv
sind wir eigentlich für Fachkräfte das
ist eine völlig andere Debatte wir haben
400.000 500.000 Menschen die in zwei
drei Jahren nach Deutschland kommen zum
großen Teil nicht im Arbeitsmarkt
ankommen und gleichzeitig ein
riesenbedarf an Arbeits- und Fachkräften
wo wir elendig lange Verfahren haben nur
eine Pflegekraft mal anzuerkennen ihren
Berufsabschlüssen insofern da sind wir
uns scheinbar dann ja einig sind diese
beiden kommuniz teilweise
kommunizierenden Röhren aber diese
beiden logischen Systeme die passen
vorne und hinten gerade nicht zusammen
das Problem ist nur dass dieser EU
Außengrenzen Schutz und das
Entscheidende an der EU Außengrenze das
propagieren wir das besprechen wir in
der EU seit Jahren und es funktioniert
seit Jahren nicht und das ist echt was
mich echt umtreibt und wir sehen hier
sie haben es ja beschrieben wir sehen in
den Städten und Gemeinden es gibt
Grenzen dessen was geht weil einfach in
den Kitas in den Schulen im
Wohnungsmarkt Integration gerade von
Menschen aus völlig anderen Kulturräumen
Integration ist riesen anstrengende
Arbeit im Alltag des dauert das braucht
Ressorts es ist mehr das Bett und dann
warm ist nochmal Grenzen dessen was geht
und deswegen geht's neben der Kontrolle
auch darüber dass wir endlich verstehen
wir haben auch Migrationen zu begrenzen
um eine überhaupt das leisten zu können
was notwendig ist das heißt wir
versuchen das jetzt wieder das was wir
die ganze Zeit schon versuchen
an der an der EU-Außengrenze versuchen
wir sozusagen die Verfahren schon zu
machen das hat jetzt jahrelang nicht
funktioniert und jetzt versuchen wir es
wieder ich weiß nicht was Einstein Herr
Weimar sie sind der fürtonistin der
Sendung der sagte immer wieder das
Gleiche zu versuchen und auf ein anderes
Ergebnis zu hoffen ist die Definition
aber es ist ja nicht richtig versucht
worden sondern es ist ja die Frage wird
darüber diskutiert ob man an bestimmten
Stellen Zäune bauen kann natürlich kann
man Zäune bauen dann der EU ausgeführt
an den Stellen wo es geographisch Sinn
macht ja weil man nur Kontrolle konnte
an den Landgrenzen zum Beispiel macht es
natürlich Sinn damit man bestimmen
konkret mal ganz ganz Türkei oder oder
Bulgarien hat dann sein Land Grenzen
auch
der andere Teil der dazu gehört eben
dort an den Grenzen entsprechende
Verfahren auch möglich zu machen aber
dann auch zügig da geht's nicht um
Monate lang sondern zügig zu entscheiden
wie soll das dort gehen also Lampedusa
sind in den letzten Tagen Wochen 2000
Menschen angekommen es ist eine kleine
Insel ich war da mal die ist dann quasi
voll aber wir müssen mal andersrum reden
damit unglaublich viel zu tun überhaupt
diese Leute erstmal von Bord dieser
Schiffe zu bringen einigermaßen
irgendwie zu versorgen vielleicht können
wir mal ein paar Bilder zum Spielen die
wir auch vorbereitet haben und mal klar
zu machen was da eigentlich passiert
also mir fehlt vollkommen auch
angesichts dieser Bilder die Fantasie
wie wie es vonstatten gehen soll dass
diese italienischen Behörden dann dort
also nicht diese Bilder wie sollen die
dort an Ort und Stelle dann auch noch
Asylverfahren durchziehen wenn ich ich
kann mir vorstellen dass die Leute
registrieren können irgendwann nach
vorne ich kann mir nicht vorstellen dass
man da noch Asylverfahren machen also
erster Teil das ist jetzt noch mal dass
ich erstens die Seegrenze und zweitens
eins von der Weg wenn wir das mal
Miteinander schaffen Wochen vielleicht
Monate lang konsequent zu zeigen es
reicht nicht einfach nur solche Richtung
Europa auf dem Weg zu machen dann bin
ich da und bleibe dann werden die Zahlen
auch irgendwann sich senken und gerade
und jetzt da wir spielen ein bisschen
schwierig darf ich mal kurz sie haben
letzte Dose eingeführt
das sind Vorschlag von mir Eingang ist
ja auch erwähnt nicht nur von mir von
vielen anderen wenn wir Menschen aus dem
Mittelmeer retten sie zurückzubringen zu
der Küste woher sie kommt das wird
übrigens in Absprache mit der Türkei ich
war in der Grieche türkischen Grenze vor
zwei drei Monaten auf der Insel Kurs da
sehen sie die Türkei schon in dem Moment
wo Boote losfahren startet die türkische
Küstenwache in Abstimmung und der
griechischen bringt die Boote und die
Schlepper zurück an die türkische Küste
das machen sie konsequent 2 3 4 5 Wochen
dann ist die Botschaft klar dieser Weg
funktioniert nicht und dann hört
übrigens auch dieses furchtbare sterben
auf dass er mir im Herzen weh tut genau
dass jedes Mal wenn das passiert
wenn die Botschaft wenn die Botschaft
ist und dabei da haben wir vielleicht
einen unterschiedliche Einschätzung wenn
die Botschaft ist wenn ich es probiere
habe ich ich am Ende eine Chance auch da
anzukommen dann werden aus guten
nachvollziehbaren Gründen im Einzelfall
viele Menschen ist probieren wenn die
Botschaft ist ist zu probieren lohnt
sich gar nicht sein Leben zu riskieren
weil es eben wenn dann zurückgeht an die
Küste von der man gekommen ist das ist
hart das ist brutal das tut im Herzen
weh aber wenn wir das jemals beenden
wollen dieses sterben dann glaube ich
müssen wir diese klare Botschaft senden
und ergänzen und da bin ich dann wieder
bei Ihnen mit Kontingenten wo man
gezielt sagt wir nehmen jedes Jahr eine
bestimmte Zahl von Menschen auf die
lassen wir von der UN auswählen dann
kommt vielleicht auch vor allem
diejenigen die am stärksten sind sondern
die ist am dringendsten brauchen Frauen
Kinder auch andere das das wenn man das
eine Zeit lang durchhält in dieser Härte
dann bin ich sehr sicher ist dass Signal
auch da ziemlich schnell dass dieser Weg
nicht mehr einer ist jetzt noch mal
Nachweis weil das ja wirklich ganz
entscheidender Punkt ist also sie sagen
wir müssen bereit sein zu dieser Härte
müssen sagen wir holen die Leute dann da
raus aus diesem Boden und bringen Sie
einfach wieder zurück zum Beispiel in
ein Land wie Libyen was die mir schlimme
Dinge hören aus in Tunesien läuft auch
gerade nicht besonders gut das sollten
wir machen wir sollten die idealerweise
mit diesen Ländern darüber über
Einkünfte haben ja okay
2009/2010 damals hat die italienische
Regierung und das Video bei lusconi mit
einem leger damals noch Lega Nord
Innenminister Maroni beschlossen jeden
der im zentral Mittelmeer von Libyen
kommt zurückzubringen
die Zahl ist drastisch gefallen auf vier
tausend im Jahr die da noch aufgebrochen
sind im Jahr 2010 es hat zwei Jahre lang
die Zahlen der Menschen die
kommentarische reduziert
und dann gab es eine Entscheidung des
Europäischen Menschenrechtsgerichtshof
der gesagt hat das ist vollkommen im
Widerspruch zu
Menschenrechtskonvention zur
Flüchtlingskonvention zu gültigen Recht
daraufhin hat Italien damit aufgehört
also was Italien jetzt macht indirekt
ist man kommuniziert mit der olympischen
Küstenwache die wohl die Leute zurück
aber
gleich zu sagen wo ich mich vollkommen
übereinstimme das Ziel muss sein
dass die schnell wachsende Zahl in
diesem Jahr sind schon über 40.000 in
der Italien kommen das ist eigentlich
die einzige schnell wachsende rote in
die Europäische Union in Italien es in
diesem Jahr viermal mehr Menschen im
zentralen mittelmeeritalien gekommen als
nach Spanien und Griechenland zusammen
also wenn wir heute im Mittelmeer von
einer Krise reden dann ist es der Weg
nach Italien dass diese Zeit fällt die
Frage ist nur wie kriegt man das so hin
dass es mit
ein Konventionen die wir haben die die
CDU auch ja in den letzten Jahren immer
unterstützt auch sind wir im Buch 2015
sie sagen ja auch und Herr Beckstein
immer gesagt dass Asylrecht ist
natürlich wichtig wir können jemand
nicht in ein Land schicken wo Menschen
gefoltert werden wie Libyen das sind
widerspricht der folterkonvention der
Menschenrechtskonvention der
Flüchtlingskonvention etc wenn man das
machen will also Glühbirne ist
eigentlich ausgeschlossen weil wir dort
keine Abkommen machen können aber ich
glaube das sehen Sie dann am Ende
ähnlich die Frage ist kann man so etwas
mit Tunesien machen
und da muss man genau hinsehen in
Tunesien gibt es gar kein Asylsystem
also wenn man heute Leute nach Tunesien
zurückbringt ohne ein Verfahren dann
heißt das Reform man bringt sie eine
Situation wo es kein Asylwesen gibt das
heißt aber nicht dass man jetzt hier
aufhören kann und sagen kann wir schauen
zu wie jeden Monat mehr Leute kommen es
bedeutet dass man sich anstrengen muss
zu verhandeln und das ist dann auch
Angebote zu machen um die Zahl der Leute
zu stoppen und das geht tatsächlich da
bin ich bei ihnen durch Rückführungen
aber dazu muss man erstens sicherstellen
dass man nur Leute zurückschickt die
dort sicher sind zum Beispiel Tunesien
nach einer schnellen Prüfung also man
kann Tunesien bringen die allermeisten
steigen bekommen in Europa keiner mehr
irgendwo das könnte man sehr schnell
machen dann braucht man ein Angebot an
Tunesien dass man sagt wir bieten legale
Migration an für Tunesien auch in den
Arbeitsmarkt sogar die italienische
Premierminister dafür bereit Deutschland
und Italien könnten jetzt darüber reden
was bietet man dafür Tunesien an und
Tunesien nimmt diese Leute zurück für
nicht Tunesier die derzeit in Tunesien
aber rassistische Reden des Präsidenten
also wirklich auch Gewalt gegen subsara
Afrikaner in Tunesien bräuchte man eine
andere Lösung wenn man ein sicheres Land
hätte in Afrika das wirklich bereit wäre
auch Asylverfahren zuzulassen daran muss
man arbeiten aber eine Punkt noch das
alles würde die deutschen Kommunen um
kein fast nicht entlasten denn die die
derzeit nach Deutschland kommen im
letzten Jahr gab es nur 4.000
Asylanträge aus Tunesien Marokko
Algerien in Deutschland also unter
diesem der Druck auf deutsche Kommunen
Leute unterzubringen ist fast
ausschließlich und darum haben wir diese
Diskussion die Ukrainerinnen und die
Diskussion die wir nicht führen 80% der
Flüchtlinge im letzten Jahr die
deutschen aufgenommen haben waren aus
der Ukraine in diesem Jahr aber nicht in
diesem Jahr
kamen bis jetzt kamen im ersten Quartal
ungefähr 80.000 u zusätzliches Ausländer
Zentralregister und 80.000 Asylsuchenden
nur aber wir werden sagen Leute mit
denen ich spreche ungefähr Jahresende
Ukraine abgezogen
300.000 Menschen ohne aber die große
ohne Ukraine
300.000 Menschen das ist ungefähr
dreimal Gütersloh das ist jetzt nicht
trivial nein aber die Zahl die wir
direkt beeinflussen können ist natürlich
die Zahl der Ukraine warum und ich
verstehe nicht warum man darüber in
Deutschland auch beim flüchtlingsgipfel
jetzt nicht redet wir haben in der EU
eine solidaritäts Entscheidung getroffen
alle Ukrainerinnen können einen
Schutzstatus überall beantragen richtige
Entscheidung Deutschland sagt für
unterstützen die Ukraine bei der Uni
Integration richtige Entscheidung aber
es steht in dieser in dieser Richtung
steht man soll einen
solidaritätsmechanismus schaffen
der mit den Folgen sich mit den Folgen
beschäftigt wenn diese Leute die durch
die Massen ins Land kommen nicht
ausgewogen verteilt werden mit zwei
Aspekten Finanzierung und die Aufnahme
wir haben eine Situation wo Polen 4%
seiner Bevölkerung Ukrainerinnen
aufgenommen hat Deutschland 1,2% und
Frankreich 0,2 %. darüber und die
Ursachen dafür liegen auf der Hand in
Frankreich kriegt eine ukrainische Frau
mit Kind ein Drittel der Unterstützung
von Deutschland
darüber auf europäischer Ebene zu sagen
liebe europäische Kollegen wir haben 5
Millionen Ukraine im letzten Jahr in der
EU haben einen Status einen Schutzstatus
beantragt wir reden überhaupt nicht
darüber dass manche Länder in der EU so
wenig Hilfe anbieten dass sie alle am
Rhein in Deutschland stehen bleiben
andere Länder haben mehr gemacht als
Deutschland aber viele Länder sehr viel
weniger das würde wirklich große Zahlen
betreffen wenn die Franzosen Spanien
Italiener nur so viele aufnehmen wie die
Tschechien während das eine Million
Menschen trotzdem
würden sie dazu stimmen ist das Thema
die Ukraine nach meinem Gefühl nicht das
Thema aber das wäre seit vielen Jahren
reden hat mit der Ukraine nichts zu tun
natürlich ist die Aufnahme von einer
Million Ukraine einen gewaltiger
vorgegangen und hat und das ist aber
auch eine gewaltige humanitäre Leistung
und ich habe den Eindruck dass in
Deutschland das von den allergrößten
Teilen der Bevölkerung auch unterstützt
und getragen genau
eine humanitäre Großstadt die
Deutschland vollbracht hat und ich finde
wir können stolz darauf sein und wir
werden die Franzosen nicht dazu bringen
mehr aufzunehmen oder mehr zu zahlen das
ist einfach ein ein Faktum in der EU
deswegen können wir unsere eigenen
moralischen Standards da nicht anpassen
auf der anderen Seite ist die
Problemlage so groß da steht doch
irgendwas
aber sie kennen die Realität in der
Europäischen Union es ist halt so er hat
vorhin Ungarn angesprochen
und dann verhalten wir uns
dementsprechend ich glaube nur dass die
flüchtlingslage wirklich dramatisch ist
im Moment die Nachrichten die wir hören
aus den Städten Dresden
bordcontainerdörfer in Südhessen
Zeltstädte bei mir im Heimatort die
Turnhalle wieder voll also es fühlt sich
wieder nach 2015 an und es ist auch in
realiter so wenn sie Bürgermeister
gelangen Sie Probleme wirklich ernst
sind die sagen dass uns Leute es ist
härter als zwei 15 weil die Zahlen
größer sind und die Stimmung von 15
Monaten fragen warum hat die AFD
eigentlich so hohenfrage gewesen
die SPD ein das ist ja eine fundamentale
Versicherung im Kräfte Gleichgewicht der
Republik in Österreich werden die
Rechten vielleicht stärkste Partei ja
und deswegen verstehe ich dass die
Bundesregierung eigentlich diesmal mit
der Opposition jetzt sagt wir müssen
ernsthaft agieren
wir Journalisten kritisieren diese
amperegierung für vieles und ich finde
auch zurecht aber in dem Punkt finde ich
haben sie jetzt ein strategischen Pfad
gefunden der den ich für richtig halte
und zwar zu sagen diese humanitäre
Immigration die betrachten wir gesondert
das werden wir immer tun wenn sowas
passiert wie Ukraine
Zuwanderung wie sie vorhin besprochen
haben Fachkräfte Zuwanderung die müssen
wir besser organisieren dass ein neues
Gesetz vorgehalte ich auch für richtig
übrigens aber die illegale Migration die
müssen wir bekämpfen und nun kommt der
Katalog von Maßnahmen was kannst du da
tun Grenzen sichern Außengrenzen
abschieben Leistungen kürzen ganz Europa
gehen die einzelnen Staaten
unterschiedlich davor ich glaube wie Sie
übrigens dass die Maßnahmen an den
Grenzen selber also Grenzen und dort
abweisungszentren zu bauen nicht wirksam
sein werden ich glaube nur das Abkommen
mit Drittstaaten dazu führen ich
verlange ja größten Spanien und kennt
die Situation dort zwischen Spanien und
Marokko ganz gut und dort ist es
natürlich hoch bris ant weil es ist sehr
nah sie sehen das
immigrationsdruck ist gewaltig und die
Spanier haben seit vielen Jahren mit dem
Marokkanern eben ein Übereinkommen wie
man das regelt und dann musst du der
marokkanischen Seite entgegenkommen und
etwas geben und sie haben es so gelöst
dass wir in diesem Jahr in Spanien ein
Rückgang der migrationszahlen von 44%
haben bei uns haben wir plus 80 %. es
ist wahrnehmen das funktioniert also das
muss konkret was machen die genau
die Marokkaner verpflichten sich
Zurücknahme und das heißt dort die
spannenden das er repulsiones in
caliente das ist heiße Rückführung das
heißt manchmal wenn die Spanier einen
Flüchtling aufnehmen eben sie den direkt
an die marokkanische Grenze Polizei ohne
Asylantrag natürlich völkerrechtlich
fragwürdig ja
das funktioniert und wenn und wenn die
Flüchtlinge merken ich ich komme hier
nicht durch weil sie Marokkaner agieren
ja auch
grenzschützen dann kommt natürlich für
weniger
zu verstehen
sie haben gerade
Gesetzestexte zitiert wir halten die
Fackel der Humanität hoch und sagen
an den Armen Marokkaner aus dem aus dem
Boden zieht und sagt bitte schön und
direkt zurück nach Hause nein und darum
Spanien ist in der EU ja und genau
immer die wirkliche Krise und das ist
auch merkwürdig an der deutschen Debatte
und zwar auch in der Kritik an Frau
Feser da wird von NGOs zum Teil so getan
als würde in Deutschland entschieden was
die Griechen die Kroaten die und andere
an ihren Grenzen machen die wirkliche
Krise ist wir haben heute an den
Außengrenzen Spanien ist nur ein
Beispiel eine ganze Reihe von
Regierungen die beschlossen haben die
einzige Chance ihr reguläre Migration zu
reduzieren ist mit Gewalt ja
zurückstoßen ohne Verfahren bitte weil
sie sich so gut auskennen bei dem Thema
also ich leite das mal ein sozusagen mit
einer Zahl ja ich glaube wir haben in
der EU mittlerweile 19 Zäune
eigentlich an allen Landgrenzen
2015 hatten wir ungefähr 300 Kilometer
Zäune heute haben wir über 2000
Kilometer das heißt mit anderen Worten
alle schotten sich ab was passiert an
den einzelnen
ist
normaler Grenzschutz und Staat und
Kontrolle von Staat heißt wenn der Staat
sagt nein hier geht's nicht weiter dann
muss Start das im Zweifel auch in der
Lage sein
bei anderen Dingen auch ich meine wenn
sie sagen dann müssen halt wir die
Flüchtlinge hier EU Recht übrigens das
ist ja nicht nur bei der Ukraine so
dürfte es in Deutschland überhaupt gar
keiner ankommen eigentlich wenn es nach
der Rechtslage geht auf jeden Fall wir
nehmen ja die Menschen nicht mit Gewalt
in Massen dann in andere Länder deswegen
muss es an der Außengrenze sowieso
entschieden werden da liegt der
Schlüssel und ich wage jetzt mal was was
wieder 1000 Shitstorms bringt aber ich
sag's trotzdem vielleicht müssen wir
tatsächlich mal drüber nachreichen
nachdenken ob die Flüchtlingskonvention
die europäische Menschenrecht Konvention
so noch funktionieren ich meine die
Flüchtlingskonvention kommt aus den 50er
Jahren die ist unter dem Eindruck des
Zweiten Weltkrieges entstanden übrigens
geilste ursprünglich nur für Europa und
die Frage ist ja macht das im Jahr 2023
so mit diesen individuellen Verfahren
monatelang ohne Klarheit für alle
Beteiligten und mit dem Botschaften die
sie sendet sind oder wäre es nicht
besser wie sie auch gesagt haben wir
arbeiten mit klaren Kontingenten
Größenordnungen zu denen wir uns
verpflichten wo die UN auch auswählt
nach bestimmten Kriterien welche
Menschen haben dringendsten auch eine
Perspektive nach Europa hinein bekommen
sollten haben aber an der Grenze eben
auch die klare Botschaft über diesen
Landweg außer aus der Ukraine ist jetzt
mal wer über den Landweg kommt per se
schon mindestens mal durch zwei drei
vier sichere Länder gegangen aber da
würde ich gerne noch mal reingehen kann
ist nicht hineingehen sondern nur über
Kontingente aber wenn Deutschland ein
Recht auf Asyl sich in die Verfassung
schreibt wenn wir das postulieren aber
den Menschen gar keine Chance geben Asyl
zu beantragen weil sie erst nach
Deutschland wandern bis Moment sie sind
um jeden von sicheren drittstanden wir
sind umgeben von sicheren Drittstaaten
ein Mensch der individuell verfolgt ist
kann mit dem Fallschirm abspringen über
Deutschland und sein Asylantrag stellen
alle die das nicht schaffen müssen
hierher laufen da kommen sie immer durch
einen sicheren drittstand damit machen
wir uns einen schlanken Fuß das haben
wir sehr lange gemacht immer unter
verweisen jetzt haben wir die Situation
Moment
Prinzip das heißt man muss in
Deutschland sich aufhalten um ein Recht
auf andere Teil im Grundgesetz da steht
drin Grundgesetz wäre aus einem sicheren
drittstadt kommt hat kein Anspruch auf
Asyl das ist die grundgesetzlage
Stellen
Asylrecht passiert sondern nach
Flüchtlingskonvention mein Punkt ich
sage das noch einmal weil ich das nicht
gut finde dass das immer so gedeutet
wird ich habe nicht gesagt wir tun
nichts es gibt übrigens kaum ein Land
auf der Welt und Europa das so viel tut
wie Deutschland auch in den Leistungen
die wir geben übrigens auch in
Krisenregionen hinein was ich gesagt
habe ist lasst es uns mit Kontingenten
machen damit Menschen sich auch erst gar
nicht auf diesen brutalen harten Weg
machen und machen müssen sondern wir
sagen meinetwegen aus einer Krisen und
kriegsregion Syrien Nordirak kommen pro
Jahr können wir jetzt diskutieren 2050
80.000 Menschen nach Deutschland die
unwählt sie aus und sie kommen auf
sicheren Wegen äh hier herüber es geht
nicht darum nicht der Verantwortung
gerecht zu werden es geht um die Frage
ob das System
derjenige der sich irgendwie
durchgekämpft hat und ich sag noch mal
hart brutal durchgekämpft hat bleibt in
jedem Fall egal aus welchem Grund er
sich auf dem Weg gemacht hat und und die
Zahl ist irgendwie unbeeinflussbar wie
lange sollen das gut gehen in fünf
Jahren zehn Jahren 15 Jahren irgendwann
kommt der Punkt war eine Mehrheit in
diesem Land sagt wir wollen das nicht
mehr wenn man das einfach so Verwalter
passieren lässt
auf die Frage antworten
haben Sie keine Angst vor diesem Punkt
der zum Beispiel auch in Dänemark der
auch im sehr liberalen
schwedenskandidat die Entwicklungen
gucken dieser Punkt bin ich total dabei
dass wir diesen Punkt nicht erreichen
dürfen das ist ganz wichtig die AFD
profitieren nämlich das Gefühl wir sind
kurz vor diesem Punkt nein was ich ja
das könnte passieren deswegen ist es ja
umso wichtiger dass jetzt aktiv zu
gestalten sie haben wieder vermischt das
Recht auf Asyl mit den humanitären
Kontingenten sie kennen Asylbewerber
nicht mit einem humanitären kontingenton
denn das individuelle Recht auf Asyl
steht jedem politisch verfolgt zu tun
wegen seiner geschlechtlichen wegen
seiner sexuellen Orientierung wegen
seiner ethischen Zugehörigkeit
da können sie nicht sagen wir nehmen
20.000
asylbewerberrecht ist für diese
Verfahren nicht einschlägig das ist
genau
möglichst in der Heimat anbieten das
muss möglich sein für politische
verfolgen in Heimatland bei der
deutschen Botschaft ein Visum zu
beantragen auf Asyl zu beantragen damit
sie sicher einreisen können und dann
dass sie beantragen können ich wollte
noch einkaufen eine Lücke
ankommen das muss man sehen wir haben
diese Probleme weil wir im Grunde
genommen das Faustrecht ist stärkeren
die sich irgendwie durchschlägt zu uns
der hat irgendwelche an